ils étaient de la chair à média un
moment oui oui
maintenant c'est une la chair à média ou
qui en souffre plus ouais c'est dur
d'être devenu une star à l'époque du
sida pourquoi non j'ai pas mal en
testard t'avoue que les bébés qui tombe
dans les bras aux noms qui n'ont pas pu
savoir que parce que tu es connu sous sa
coupe
d'abord j'avais plus de succès franc
j'ai l'impression que le succès qu il
croit que les filles n'aiment pas
pourquoi je préfère être aimé pour les
bonnes raisons et pas pour le fait que
j'ai un compte en banque soit très
correct parce qu'on est ce que tu es
prêt pour l'interview coq à l'âne sur
l'image
est ce que tu préfères lennon ou ma
carte mais je pense en les maintenant
pourquoi j'ai jamais aimé ma carte neige
tombe
enfin comme ça j'ai pas tyran et variait
taper pis pour les jeunes
maintenant c'est vrai qu'on ouvre enfin
s'ils subissent une année 110 80 ans
pour qui a le culte et roule ouzou et si
possible martyrs marc décor fait qu'elle
est la dernière personne qui a eu envie
de tuer
j'ai eu envie de tuer sabatier quand
j'ai vu avec gainsbourg
ah ouais ah oui parce que se trouvait au
demi s'ils préfèrent les hippies pour
les yeux sur les hippies à mort je peux
faire le culte de trèbes à battre ça
dans les maquis du batave pas
principales banques tout bas mais je
trouve que c'était des années est
d'abord d'idées fortes alors que l'idée
fort de gagner de l'argent est moins
intéressante que l'idée forte de
développer anti-jo développer son
psychisme
d'être très généreux vers l'extérieur
baba forcément parce que sinon je suis
les principes qui sont intéressants ceux
qui en ont
dis donc t'es déjà pensé à se suicider
oui ce consensus il ya des gens et quand
c'était je crois en 81 81 81 ans j'ai
juste avant justement ce n'est noir à
lormont
tu disais ça marchera jamais je sais pas
quoi faire de ma vie j'ai du talent
personne ne pouvait pas aller plus loin
et ça c'était affreux et bien dire gars
de sortir complètement inutiles comme ça
une époque j'ai beaucoup où c'était le
chaos etienne capoue et je n'aimais pas
du tout j'avais plein de choses à régler
et j'ai fait une dépression très très
forte très dur et
j'ai eu envie de sauter par la fenêtre
du huitième étage à l'époque ce prix
bureau n'a pas trouvé de mieux à faire
c'est parce qu'il est capricorne en
vieillissant il s'améliore ouais
est ce que tu crois que l'amour est
compatible avec le mariage je pense ils
croient pas mais je pense ou parce que
j'ai vu des cas bonjour nous avons vu
quelles choses négatives tu dirais sur
toi sur moi je suis trop anxieux il trop
anxieux et j'ai tendance à me
dévaloriser trop souvent alors si
important c'est d'avoir conscience de sa
valeur ses qualités ses défauts
c'est encore était fausse modestie herbe
oui selon diane des catherinettes dents
de scie ce à quoi c'est ce dimanche que
les régies des halles pour une autre
femme fait quoi pour toi il n'ya pas de
dieu ça peut être n'importe où n'importe
quand n'importe où c est le lieu le plus
fou alors tout à fait l'amour c'est pas
un lieu très poussée assez conventionnel
sans ascenseur parce que tout le monde
en parle mais les gens au motif qu elle
talent de jacques pouliquen des
candidats le club ne prenait pas de
risques le lieu où tu serais incapable
de faire l'amour par contre là là avec
moi l'ufip a raison